the viennese doctor and psychoanalyst
sigmund freud hypnotized his patients
interpreted dreams and
thereby discovered the vast dimensions of the
unconscious every human being is so happy has
hidden desires drives and longings
that influence his life without him
realizing it
the infant still lives according to the
principle of pleasure he takes everything  screams into his mouth
when something is desired and laughs
when he is doing well, yes, but he must
soon learn that he must obey the parents, the
teachers and their rules
and the infantile principle of pleasure, yes,
only we live according to the libido,
that must give way to the principle of reality
every earthling  had to make this sad
experience that instead of lust
and the lust principle, the reality principle
takes its place and in the course of our
socialization there are often
insults and traumatizations
freud was a doctor and practiced a
revolutionary treatment
method which psychoanalysis was the first to discover,
namely that
people’s attitude to life  often stems from experiences
the two are in the past which
are still effective and which can
also be emotionally re-evaluated in psychoanalysis
in the small book Freude in 60
Minuten his revolutionary new view
of people and the mental
illness of many  with examples and
quotes all the
important building blocks of his theory are explained step by step, from
the oral phase the oedipus conflict the
drive conflict sublimation
repression resistance and
symptom formation to therapy
build on one another in
the second part of the book the question is
asked what is the use and we are happy about the discovery
today and you will see it is
really amazing how helpful his
insights can be for our very
personal way of life
if you use them correctly